partes like to share stories about
sparks of inspiration that motivate them
to create when it comes to HBO's new
adaptation of His Dark Materials that
spark happens to be one very distressing
plight in an interview with the Los
Angeles Times His Dark Materials
executive producer Jane Tranter revealed
that a terrifying experience while
flying was behind her push to bring
Philip Pullman's popular fantasy novel
series to the small screen the incident
happened around five years ago while
Tranter was on a flight from Los Angeles
to New York during the flight to silence
fell over the passengers as the plane
began to quickly lose altitude as
Tranter tells it the pilots jumped into
action and prepared to make an emergency
landing in Chicago Tranter became
emotionally overwhelmed too afraid to
finish the work she was doing so she
turned to her kindle instead to comfort
herself Tranter began reading the end of
Pullman's the amber spyglass the final
book in the author's best-selling His
Dark Materials trilogy Tranter told the
LA Times the books are so spiritual and
they have got so much to say about her
human mortality and what death means in
separation it took me to another world
the experience convinced Tranter to
follow up on the rights of Pullman's
books a curiosity that led her straight
into the offices of New Line Cinema the
studio had already attempted to adapt
the books to film in 2007 but ultimately
dropped those plans after the first
installment The Golden Compass
underperformed both critically and at
the box office
that's why light saga New Moon director
Chris Weitz helmed and wrote that
particular Pohlman adaptation which
caused the studio 180 million dollars to
make but only earned around 70 million
dollars domestically with most of its
box office taking it's coming from
overseas the Golden Compass also faced
hurdles beyond its inability to draw a
crowd for example Pullman's books were
fiercely critical of both the Catholic
Church and Christianity in general
Philip Pullman is a nona atheist he's
been known to be pushing on kids for a
long time he put out a DVD for example
in England that says why a Thea
as a result they became the subject of
intense debate and scrutiny by some
religious audiences and the 2007 movie
was no different the story was so
controversial that in the year after the
film's shaky release the Golden Compass
landed in the American Library
Association's list of top ten books that
individuals and organizations had
attempted to have banned
in the United States near line attempted
to curb some of this reaction to the
film by watering down the film's
religious content but other critics and
audiences seem to think that decision
hurt more than it helped the narrative
despite a less than stellar box-office
turnout and the controversy surrounding
the original movie Tranter convinced
studio executives that Pullman's fantasy
could live again on the small screen she
and the rest of the His Dark Materials
team were able to persuade not only new
line executives that the television
adaptation was worth the risk but also
several high-profile stars including
James McAvoy brute Wilson and lin-manuel
Miranda it's a win Tranter attributed to
another popular HBO adaptation which
helped make the case that an elaborate
fantasy like Pullman's could both be
done and be well-received Tranter
explained Game of Thrones really did
that job for me not many movies that
struggle at the box-office get a second
chance on the small screen and Tranter
took a risk with His Dark Materials but
it seems that her leap of faith has paid
off in kind as a response to the small
screen adaptation has been stellar so
far holding an 84% critical rating and a
92% audience score on Rotten Tomatoes
His Dark Materials is being praised for
its impressive performances strong
visuals and its ability to capture the
spirits of Pullman's original novels one
critic even wrote that the show is proof
that TV is now the best medium for
bringing epic literary fantasy to the
screen almost makes that death-defying
flight worth it don't you think check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]